I like miss him all the time No
your ears aren't deceiving you that's
Chloe saying she misses her ex lamar
odom
in a sneak peak at Sunday's episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Chloe
opens up to Kim and Kourtney about where
things stand with her ex-husband
I like miss him all the time but not in
a place that I could want to get back
with him so he called me and he was like
I just knew we were all gonna talk again
at some point I'm just so happy he was
like I would love to see you I've been
dying to see you in person I just feel
that we have so much to talk about so
what did Chloe's big sis have to say
about Lamar's attempts to reconnect I
mean I think it would be nice if you
guys like how to face-to-face after all
these years I just feel like maybe you
have to get that out Khloe and Lamar
tied the knot in 2009 just one month
after they met what did it mean to be
married to Chloe and what does Chloe
still mean to you today Oh a lot you
know yeah in 2013 the marriage was hit
hard by Lamar's cheating scandal and
drug relapse she was loving you but
there were other woman yeah lots of
other women are good what was it well if
you marry one is two you know I'm saying
you got one at home dealing with another
one has weight that's one too many and
by December Chloe had filed for divorce
was she the love of your life yeah yeah
would you or could you have stayed with
her yeah but you know when we radically
fighting those demons you can't even
really you're not loving yourself yeah
so you can't even spread the love to
someone that's loving you as much as she
loved me but the two were still legally
married when Lamar was hospitalized
following a near-death overdose in 2015
and as a result Khloe who was making all
of his medical decisions opted to call
off their divorce proceedings how much
you think you hurt her I mean a lot yeah
yeah a lot
I'm blessed just for evenness to pick up
my phone call in 2016
Chloe refiled for divorce and it was
finalized later that year I always felt
after I think this overdose that I did
everything in my power to like be there
who like sickness and health and once I
saw that he you know wasn't in the head
space to really want to change his bad
situation then I was fine yeah letting
him go it I've never thought twice about
it and why we stopped talking or
anything like that yeah but Chloe did
admit she was happy to hear his voice
it feels really good just to have a
decent nice conversation with Lamar but
you know I really don't know what the
right thing to do is in this situation I
don't want to mislead him in any way but
I would like to meet with him have you
guys kind of made amends now is it as a
come full circle um I mean I wouldn't
call it amends I've spoke spoken so I
recently if you call that a minute so
what do you think about her interest in
dementia that is this bad situation she
doesn't deserve that she's a beautiful
person from the inside out yeah you know
just a man I guess being as stupid as I
was
[Music]